I'll tell you a story  finds about revenge  can't happen thank yours is too  [Music]  I've lived here my whole life  I've seen hell and I made hell  so long sergeant  just do you remember and there you've  been one of us but out here  you wanted them  not to fight don't pick  it was black magic  only this afternoon you were tied up  there I was lying down over there both  about to get killed and yet here we are  and it's everyone else that's dead  someone killed my child but now I'm not  gonna kill me  [Music]  will you help me  can you shoot I have to  oh you'll have to  quite the woman I expected you're  everything I'd expect of a man  [Laughter]  there's just something about this  country  wonder if that  [Music]  drifted